[Music]
Andrew Ng:What are your thoughts on where all this will go?
Chris Manning: I think there's just no doubt at
all the future is extremely bright. We're moving
into this age where human language will be able
to be used as an instruction language to
tell your computer what to do. One way to
think about the differences in comparison
to the kind of voice assistance or virtual
assistants that are available. I think all of
us have had the experience that those devices
aren't always great. If you know the right way
to word things that'll do something but if you
use the wrong wording it won't. The difference
with human beings is by and large you don't have
to think about that. I think that we'll start
to see the same kind of progression with these
models. That age is opening up in front of
us and that will be hugely transformative.